[Musik]
wärst du gerne ein Junge und frei
waschen
[Musik]
die Kinder Afghanistans haben
jahrzehntelang Konflikte und Leid
ertragen müssen doch seit dem Abzug der
US-Truppen vor einem Jahr und der
Machtübernahme durch die Taliban ist das
Leben für die meisten Afghanen noch
schwerer geworden
das Land steckt in einer schweren
humanitären Krise und Sanktionen haben
die ohnehin schwache Wirtschaft
erschüttert
die Unterernährung von Kindern hat
ebenso zugenommen wie die Kinderarbeit
die Menschen sind verarmt und es sind
vor allem die Frauen und Mädchen die
darunter zu leiden haben
die besten Freundinnen schuglia und
adeso haben während der Macht Ergreifung
der Taliban beide ihre Väter verloren
wie so viele in diesem Land sind ihre
Mütter ungebildet und finden keine
Arbeit
einerseits aufgrund des Arbeitsmangels
andererseits weil die Taliban nicht
wollen dass Frauen arbeiten
wie Tausende von Kindern hier sind auch
shukria und areso gezwungen auf der
Straße zu betteln
[Musik]
warum ist deine Familie seit der
Machtübernahme der Taliban ärmer
geworden
[Musik]
Frauen und Mädchen führen im heutigen
Afghanistan ein hartes und isoliertes
Leben die Taliban haben ihre Bildung
eingeschränkt und ihnen die Teilnahme an
fast allen Bereichen des öffentlichen
Lebens untersagt
aber auch das Leben einiger jungen hat
sich drastisch verändert
der achtjährige Abdullah ist der Sohn
eines militärischen Oberbefehlshabers
der Taliban als die Taliban hier die
machtübernahmen wurde sein Vater ein
hochrangiger Beamter in der neuen
Regierung
wenn er nicht gerade für seinen Vater
und seine Kameraden Wache schiebt
verbringt Abdullah seine Tage mit dem
Studium das Korans an einer religiösen
Schule der sogenannten Madrasa er ist
ein wahrer Gläubiger
[Musik]
der achtjährige examula ist Abdullahs
bester Freund sein Vater ist der
persönliche Assistent von Abdullahs
Vater
[Musik]
was ist für dich der Unterschied
zwischen einer Schule und der Matratze
der Koranschule
[Musik]
viele afghanische Frauen sind
analphabetenen ein Erbe aus der Zeit als
die Taliban vor mehr als 20 Jahren schon
einmal an der Macht waren die
Alphabetisierungsrate der Frauen hat
sich in den letzten zehn Jahren während
der westlichen Besatzung verdoppelt aber
die Taliban drehen die Uhr nun wieder
zurück sie haben die Sekundarschulen für
Mädchen geschlossen und damit die
Hoffnungen und Träume einer neuen
Generation zunichte gemacht
noch können Mädchen im Grundschulalter
in Afghanistan zur Schule gehen aber da
viele von ihnen arbeiten müssen Enten
junge Mädchen wie schukliya und arisu
bettelnd auf der Straße anstatt in den
Unterricht zu gehen
Jungen haben die Wahl zwischen der
Schule und der von den Taliban
bevorzugten Optionen den Madrasas
aber auch unter den Taliban glauben
manche das Bildung der Schlüssel für die
Zukunft sei
[Musik]
Vater besucht eine Privatschule von der
er hofft dass sie seinen Sohn aufnimmt
wunderschön
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
selbst diejenigen in höheren Positionen
stehen vor Herausforderungen aber am
anderen Ende des sozialen Spektrums gibt
es eine wachsende Unterschicht von
Menschen die versuchen der Spirale ihrer
Verzweiflung zu entkommen
[Musik]
inzwischen 13 Jahre alter Bruder ist
einer von Millionen Afghanen die
entweder Opium oder heroinabhängig sind
es ist wie eine Epidemie die durch das
Leid die Armut und die
Hoffnungslosigkeit genährt wird
Mutter hat die Hilfe einer örtlichen
Drogenbeauftragten in Anspruch genommen
um ihren Sohn aufzuspüren
[Musik]
können danke
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
findet ihr das Frauen Schwachsinn
wenn Männer zu Hause sitzen müssten und
nicht arbeiten dürfen wie wäre das
wenn du 500 Dollar hättest was würdest
du damit machen
[Musik]
eines Tages als sie fleißig Schuhe
putzte hatte schuhcria eine zufällige
Begegnung die ihr Leben verändern sollte
der Filmstudent Ali fragte sie ob sie
bei einer youtube-sendung über die
Straßenkinder von Kabul mitmachen wolle
[Musik]
innerhalb weniger Monate ist schugria zu
einem lokalen Star geworden
tausende schauen sich ihre
YouTube-Videos an sie wird überall
erkannt und verdient etwas Geld fast
genug um ihrem Leben als schuhputzerin
zu entkommen
[Musik]
verstehst du die beiden Seiten die du
gelernt hast
[Musik]
neuester YouTube-Star steht jetzt hinter
der Kamera ein Zuschauer hat dir eine
Kamera gekauft und Schuck Ria will
unbedingt besser damit umgehen können
[Musik]
was willst du werden wenn du erwachsen
bist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese YouTube-Videos haben schugrias
Leben verändert die Tage an den sie am
Straßenrand saß und Schuhe putzte liegen
vorerst hinter ihr aber eine noch
größere Chance sowohl für Sie als auch
für Aristo ist in greifbarer Nähe
gemacht
und arrezo sind noch jung genug um nach
den neuen taliban-vorschriften zur
Schule gehen zu dürfen mit der Hilfe
eines privaten Sponsors können Sie sich
in einer Schule anmelden
wie wirst du deine Lehrer behandeln
[Musik]
Vater hat endlich eine Schule gefunden
die er sich leisten kann
[Musik]
wie würdest du reagieren wenn dein Vater
angegriffen wurde
[Musik]
liebst du deinen Vater sehr
vier Jahrzehnte Krieg haben Afghanistan
ausgelaugt Armut und Hunger haben großes
Leid verursacht aber irgendwo in der
Dunkelheit gibt es einen
Hoffnungsschimmer in den Köpfen der
Kinder
[Musik]